the movie opens with two men arriving at
a secret US military base amidst a harsh
blizzard standing before a mirror they
present their ID cards for verification
a light above them flickers on revealing
an operator on the other side holding a
phone after confirming their identities
as the replacement team the operator
grants them access through a concealed
door reaching for a safe the operator
gives each of the men one gun and three
bullets after signing the register they
go to a thick steel door which swings
open revealing two other men emerging
from a room their shift is over and
these two are about to replace them for
the night these men are United States
Air Force strategic missile Wing
controllers who are entrusted with keys
required to launch a missile attack the
two men settle into their workstations
and begin their shift however one of
them notices that two red bulbs at
Station 8 are still blinking indicating
a warhead alert the senior officer
believing it to be a technical glitch
resets the Warhead alarm live feeds of
nuclear missile Warheads appear on the
screens in the chamber suddenly an alarm
blares from a speaker and a code is
transmitted to the two officers on duty
following protocol they open a
restricted Locker retrieve two red cards
containing top secret missile launch
codes and match them with the code
received over the speaker they then
enter the launch code into their
computers to their horror the launch
order is confirmed and a 60-second
countdown to missile launch commences as
per procedure the two officers open the
missile launcher Gates and activate all
10 nuclear missiles preparing them for
launch with the countdown reaching 40
seconds the senior officer breaks
protocol by requesting to speak with a
higher authority on the phone but his
calls go unanswered the countdown
plummets to less than 10 seconds and
while the junior officer is poised to
launch the missiles using his key the
senior officer is paralyzed by fear
realizing that launching the missiles
could result in the deaths of at least
20 million people sensing his superior's
hesitation the junior officer points his
revolver at him and forcefully urges him
to turn his key prepared to shoot him if
he fails to comply with protocol the
officers are unaware that the event they
are experiencing is a nuclear attack
drill the drill aims to assess the
willingness of officers to make the
agonizing decision of initiating a
nuclear strike the scene shifts and we
see a helicopter descending onto the
noad combat operations center in
Cheyenne Mountain Complex Colorado two
FBI agents Lyle Watson and Arthur kabot
disembark and are escorted into a
secluded sealed office for a meeting
with Dr John mckitrick the head of
computer operations as mckitrick settles
into a meeting with the two FBI agents
and two high ranking generals agent
kabat reveals that they must leave
within an hour for a meeting with the
president of the United States their
purpose is to discuss the outcomes of
the unannounced nuclear missile launch
drill which revealed that 22% of the
officers entrusted with launching
nuclear missiles were unwilling to do so
in response General Binger announces he
will Implement a stricter psychological
screening program to eliminate such
individuals from this exceptionally
demanding responsibility in a heated
discussion mckitrick says says that
human presence in the final launch
decision will only cause this scenario
to happen again and again his secretary
adds that the time to respond in case of
a nuclear attack from Russia is not
enough to consider for human conscience
hence mckitrick concludes that it should
be left on a machine to immediately act
on whatever decision is relayed from the
president despite General beringer's
disapproval mckitrick persuades the FBI
agents to examine their War operation
plan response computer this
sophisticated machine learning program
continuously Gathers and analyzes data
then simulates War scenarios between the
US and the USSR in the form of a game
through its countless simulations
devises strategies to maintain American
dominance nitri convinces the agents to
implement his plan of replacing the wing
Control Officers with an electronic
relay system effectively removing human
involvement from the final launch
decision and entrusting it to W far from
the noad base in Seattle we find a young
David Lightman running light for his bi
biology class when he reaches his class
he sits behind his friend Jennifer Mack
who is equally unmotivated and
struggling with Biology their teacher
bluntly informs David that he has got an
F in his exams David's snarky remark
towards his teacher lands him in the
principal's office a familiar
destination for him however as he nears
the principal's door he discovers the
password to the School's district
computer system hidden underneath a desk
later that afternoon he invites Jennifer
to his room where he hacks into the
school's computer system using the
password he found earlier he proceeds to
change his biology grade from a f to a c
and does the same with Jennifer's grades
when she protests he first changes her
grade back to a f but later changes it
to an a without her knowledge during
dinner that night David sees an
advertisement of a new game from a
computer game company based in sunale
California intending to see the program
behind their game he programs his
computer to scan a list of telephone
numbers in son ofil and dial every
number in search for the computer game
company the next day Jennifer apologizes
to David and asks him to change her
biology grades they head to his room
where David reveals he has already
changed her grade to in a meanwhile his
computer is still dialing numbers to
find the game company when he
accidentally connects to an unidentified
system David asks the system to list
games in hopes of finding those from the
company the system responds with a list
including Falcon's maze Bridge Checkers
back gamon poker and global
thermonuclear war he then prints the
list and takes it to two of his hacker
friends mvin and Jim on David's
provocation Jim tells him about the
backdoor method where the designer of
the system keeps one password to bypass
any security measures that may be added
later unsure of the password mvin
suggests looking for clues in the first
game Falcon's maze David then heads to
the library to search for information on
the creator of the game Falcon's maze
where he learns that the game was
created by Dr Steven Falcon disappointed
David discovers that his computer
program blocks any information related
to the name Falcon un deterred he
continues his search at the library
after a week of research he finds that
Dr Falcon developed a machine learning
program that allowed a computer to play
games like chess and poker learning from
its mistakes and improving its skills
with each game sadly according to a
newspaper article Dr Falcon died young
at 41 after his son Joshua and wife
passed away in a car accident suddenly
David connects the dots and guesses that
the password might be Joshua after
Falcon's son his hunch is correct David
enters the passord password and the
system grants him access however he is
unaware that he has connected to wpr at
the noad combat Operation Center not a
gaming computer system in Sun ofil
Joshua is the backdoor password into wpr
allowing the user to bypass all other
security systems and enter the Mainframe
wpr recognizes him as Dr Falcon and
invites him to play chess paking it for
a game David orders it to play global
thermonuclear war instead he chooses to
play as the Soviet Union and commands
the launch of nuclear missiles at Las
Vegas and Seattle over at Colorado
David's action triggers alarm Bells at
noad warning of at least 28 missiles
from the Soviet Union headed towards the
Western US general Binger orders dfn
levels to be push to three bomber
airplanes to start patrolling and the
president to be notified of the
situation before he can proceed further
David's mother calls him downstairs to
take out the trash forcing him to shut
down his computer as a result of this
WAP turns off its missile alert and the
situation returns to normal for the time
being soon enough noad officials
discover that someone from outside
triggered the nuclear missile attack
simulations in wpr and trace it back to
Seattle meanwhile David learns from the
news that he has triggered a full-scale
nuclear alert at noad panicking at the
prospect of being arrested he calls
Jennifer who advises him to Simply stop
calling the number however while
cleaning his room he receives a call
from wpr informing him about the
progress of his game by that time the
game has been running for 31 hours 12
minutes and 49 seconds with an estimated
remaining time of 52 hours and 17
minutes when asked about the game's
purpose wpr simply states that the only
goal is to win suddenly David's phone
rings and startled he immediately pulls
the wire out what David doesn't know is
that his actions haven't gone unnoticed
later that afternoon while he is coming
out of a local shop FBI agents surround
him search him and ly escort him into a
car they are taking him to Colorado for
questioning meanwhile at noad the
situation has become tense once more the
wpr system continues to simulate a
nuclear war generating counter moves for
both the US and the Soviet Union this
escalating simulation has real world
consequences in response to the
perceived threat of us bombers that
General Binger ordered earlier the
Soviets have also raised their alert
level pushing
dfc4 meanwhile David arrives at the noad
facility and everyone is informed of his
actions Dr mckitrick requests a private
conversation with David and takes him to
his office he accuses David of tampering
with the computer system resulting in
the escalation of defc levels from 5 to
potentially 1 David admits to initially
breaching the system to play a video
game but denies any further contact
instead he claims that Joshua the
computer system at noad was the one who
contacted him however mckitrick suspects
that David is collaborating with someone
out outside the US and relaying
sensitive information tempers flare and
mckitrick receives a phone call
prompting him to rush outside he is
informed that wpr has been compromised
again and the missile launch codes are
at risk despite mri's recommendation to
remain calm General Binger raises defc
levels to three and orders us bombers to
keep patrolling the skies monitoring
Soviet movements tensions are mounting
rapidly both on us and USSR sides
meanwhile inside the office mckitrick
secretary observes David interacting
with the computer and quickly informs
the others inside the office David
communicates with W who informs him that
its final plan is to elevate DFC levels
to one and launch the US missiles
towards the USSR in 28 hours wpr is
unable to differentiate between a game
and reality and continues to simulate
the initial scenario of Soviet nuclear
missiles attacking the US the system
then reveals weird information it says
that Dr falcon is difficult to reach
both at his Seattle terminal and at a
classified location intrigued David asks
about the classified address to which
the system responds Dr Richard Hume AA
Steven Falcon Tall Cedar Road Colorado
before David can utter another word he
is apprehended by FBI agents and
informed that he will face Espionage
charges as he is being dragged away he
shouts to mckitrick that Joshua is the
one instigating this game and will
initiate World War III if not stopped
call Falcon please call Falcon he cries
out before being locked behind a secure
door using an ingenious plan and a tape
recorder David successfully unlocks the
door and escapes the noad facility
amidst a group of tourists on tour after
hitchhiking on a Lumber Truck he uses a
pay phone to contact Jennifer and
requests her to book a flight to Oregon
however Jennifer surprises him by
arriving in person David reveals to
Jennifer that he believes Dr Steven
Falcon is still alive and they embark on
a journey to Oregon together in a
Lakeside Cottage in Oregon the two
youngsters find Dr Steven Falcon who has
been living under the Alias Dr Richard
Hume meanwhile back at noad General
Binger receives an alert about two
missiles approaching Alaska accompanied
by two Russian fighter jets taking
charge and monitoring the live feed on
his screen the general orders 2 F-16
Jets to intercept the missiles in Alaska
and report back with visual confirmation
contrary to the live feed the pilots
report that no missiles or Russian Jets
have been detected by their Radars in
Alaska as if mocking the general the
missile tracks on his screen simply
disappear indicating no Russian attack
on the wpr clock we see the timer ticks
down indicating that only 14 hours
remain until it starts launching the
missiles without anyone's knowledge the
scene shifts to Dr Falcon who is sitting
with the kids and discussing his
philosophy towards life it's evident
from the conversation that he has
developed a very pessimistic worldview
following the death of his son he
explains that the primary purpose of
creating wpr was to simulate nuclear war
without actually engaging in one
demonstrating that there are no winners
in a nuclear conflict however the
individuals in the War Room at noad
stubbornly maintained their belief in
their ability to win a nuclear war and
that there could be acceptable levels of
human casualties as a result he simply
resigned and they staged a fake death
for him the kids try to reason with Dr
Falcon reminding him that his Outlook
would be less Bleak if his son Joshua
were still alive they urg him to make at
least a phone call to noad officials to
clarify the situation in response he
welcomes them to stay the night in his
cabin and then retires to his bedroom
frustrated the kids leave the cabin in
search of a boat to depart outside they
find no boat and are unable to leave the
island since David cannot swim he has a
breakdown regretting his procrastination
and learning how to swim because he
always assumed he would have enough time
the young boy wishes he had never
learned about any of this and that the
world could return to normal suddenly Dr
Falcon appears in a helicopter and urges
the kids to join him as they are running
late to save the day the scene shifts to
the noad where General Binger is alerted
about 300 Soviet intercontinental
ballistic missiles heading towards the
us when the general asks Dr mckitrick if
this is once again just a simulation he
replies that the W is functioning
perfectly hence this cannot be a
simulation in response the general
orders DFC N1 and orders the US bombers
and submarines to get ready to retaliate
to the attack when they read the initial
report report from wpr they see that the
first strike from the Soviet Union is a
fullscale attack on the US and hence
their retaliation should also be all out
meanwhile the Soviets are still denying
initiating any attack but wpr warns of a
Soviet submarine being detected the
general orders to lock down the entire
Cheyenne Mountain Complex and initiate
launch mode fortunately David Jennifer
and Dr Falcon crash into the no ad
facility and burst into the War Room
Just in Time Dr Falcon fr atically
informs General Binger that the nuclear
attack they are witnessing is merely a
simulation not reality however the
general remains unconvinced Dr mckitrick
asserts that the system is functioning
flawlessly and there is no indication of
a simulation General Binger is compelled
to believe this as the consequences of
questioning the system's accuracy could
be disastrous Dr Falcon attempts to
reason with the general questioning why
the enemy would risk a full scale attack
when they are well aware that it would
result in their own Annihilation he
emphasizes that there would be no
Victors in such a scenario making it
utterly illogical finally he persuades
the general to delay the US retaliation
until the Soviet missiles reach their
targets the countdown reaches its end
and the impact time arrives however no
missiles strike the US and targeted us
bases report no damage attention
dissipates and everyone breathes a
collective sigh of relief however Dr
Falcon observes that wpr continues to
proceed with the simulated Soviet
nuclear attack ignoring Dr m attempts to
regain control and stand down the
missiles wpr relentlessly generates
numerous passwords to crack the 10ar
launch codes for the US nuclear missiles
upon success it will initiate the launch
of thousands of missiles towards the
Soviet Union disconnecting W would
trigger an immediate missile launch as
the system would interpret it as nad's
destruction disarming the missiles is
not an option as they only have
approximately 5.3 minutes remaining
seeing every option fail Dr Falcon and
David Infiltrate The wpr System and
challenge it to a game of tic-tac-toe
against itself the system repeatedly
draws the game and as a machine learning
program it learns the concept of a draw
meanwhile wpr also acquires the 10
character nuclear launch code and
initiates the launch sequence however
before fully launching all missiles it
simulates various nuclear war scenarios
and concludes that there is no winner in
any scenario the machine realizes that a
nuclear strike by one power against
another another inevitably leads to the
complete annihilation of both Nations as
a result it relinquishes control of the
system and invites Dr Falcon to play a
game of chess instead as the final
credits roll in everyone is celebrating
and we see the message the only winning
move is to not play on the screen